so the terminology that you mentioned
is weaponized as sort of safe spaces
or that certain conversations make
people feel unsafe
what do you think about this kind of
idea
you know is is is there some things
that are unsafe to talk about in the
university setting
is there lines to be drawn somewhere and
just like you said on the flip side with
a slippery slope
is it too easy for the lines to be drawn
everywhere
yeah that's a great question so this
idea of unsafe
space at least the vocabulary derives
from
some research uh academic research
about feeling psychologically uh
unsafe and so the notion here is that
there
is uh there are forms of uh
psychological disquiet that impedes
people from uh experiencing the
educational environment
to the greatest degree possible and
that's the
argument uh i
and assuming for a moment that uh people
do have these feelings of
of of disquiet uh at
elite universities like mit and like
harvard
that's probably the safest space people
are going to be in for
their their lives because when they get
out into the the quote unquote real
world
uh they won't have the um the sorts of
uh
nets that these schools provide safety
nets that these schools
provide uh so to the extent that
research
is descriptive of a psychological
feeling
i think that the duty of the
universities uh are to challenge
people it seems to me that it's a shame
to go to a place like harvard a place
like mit yale
any of these uh great institutions and
come out
the same person that you were when you
went in
that seems to be a horrible waste of
four years and and
and money and and resources rather uh we
ought to challenge
uh students that they grow um uh
challenge some of the
uh their most deeply held assumptions
they they may continue to hold them but
the point of an education
is to rigorously interrogate um
these fundamental assumptions that have
guided you
thus far and to do it uh fairly
and and civilly so to extend that there
are lines that should be drawn uh
there's a long tradition
in the university of civil discourse so
you should
draw a line somewhere between civil
discourse and
uncivil discourse the purpose of a
university is to talk
difficult conversations tough issues
uh talk directly and frankly uh but do
it civilly
and you know so to you know yell and
cuss at somebody
uh and that sort of thing well you know
do that
on your own space but observe the
norms of civil discourse at the
university
uh so look i think that the
presumption ought to be that
uh the most difficult topics are
appropriate
to talk about at a universe that that
ought to be the presumption
now you know should uh
um mit for example
give its prom imprimatur to
someone who is espousing uh the flat
earth theory
you know the earth is flat right so
there
if if certain ideas uh
are are so uh
contrary to the scientific uh
and and cultural thinking of the of the
moment
yeah there's space there to draw a line
and say yeah we're not going to
uh give you this platform to uh tell our
students that the earth
is is is flat uh but
you know it's a topic that's
controversial
but contestatory that's what
universities
are for if you don't like the idea
present better ideas
and articulate them and i i think there
needs to be a mechanism
outside of the space of ideas of
humbling like i've done
martial arts for a long time i got my
ass kicked a lot
i think that's really important i mean
the in the space of ideas
i mean even just in engineering just all
the math classes
my memories of math which i love
is it's kind of pain is basically coming
face to face with the
with the idea that i'm not special
that i am much dumber than i thought i
was
and that anything accomplishing anything
in this world requires really hard work
that's really humbling
that makes you that that puts you
because i remember when i was 18 and 19
and i thought i was going to be the
smartest the best
fighter the the nobel prize winning uh
you know all those kinds of things and
then you come with
face to face with reality and it hurts
and
it feels like there needs to be
efficient mechanisms from the best
universities in the world
to without abusing you it's a very
difficult line to
to walk without like uh mentally or
physically abusing you
be able to humble you and that's what i
felt was missing in these very difficult
very important conversations
is the 19 year olds when they spoke up
the mechanism for humbling them with
ideas
was missing i got kind of gotten broken
broken down because as you say there
does
like i sensed fear
every everything was permeated with fear
and fear is
uh paralyzing fear is destructive
especially in a place that's supposed to
be all about
freedom of ideas
you